it seems obvious that there's
intelligent civilizations out there
now I don't know what Intel how to
define intelligence but there's
beautiful complexity like when you look
at a I've looked at enough cellular
automata which is a very primitive
mathematical
construction that when you run
complexity emerges I've looked at that
enough to know that it just seems like
there's complexity everywhere out there
so I that's why I'm deeply puzzled by
the the Fermi Paradox it makes no sense
to me I mean uh that have trivial
answers to it why haven't aliens at
scale not shown up
I I think the the two possible options
for me is either we're too dumb to see
it they're already here they've been
talking to us through processes we just
don't understand like like what we
experience as a life here on Earth is
actually they're everywhere conscious
aliens could be Consciousness that when
we feel love for one another that could
be aliens when we I don't know or feel
fear or whatever that could be aliens I
have to agree with you none of this is
scientifically provable right now we
talked a little bit already about that
but I would say that I
do not adhere to the Fermi Paradox
because it's very entreprene morphic
it's you know it's an interesting
exercise let's put it that way but it's
a typical example of seeing the universe
through our own eyes and this is what
the limitation is
understanding what's going on with
complexity as you said and looking at
the biophysical model and theories for
the nature of life I would agree that
probably
this extraterrestrial message is all
around us we're not yet capable of
picking it up
but I think unfortunately even though
that makes me sad the way to pick it up
is by studying life here on Earth doing
some of the science you're doing better
understand the nature of life until you
realize
uh holy crap the thing I was looking for
all along has been has been here all
along right well you know a good example
of that and it doesn't need to be
an extraterrestrial civilization look at
something that I really you know whether
or not is real I don't care because in
terms of intellectual exercise I think
it's fantastic look at the shadow
biosphere
the idea that life didn't appear
only once on Earth but there were many
different Pathways of it and
today we know when we study
the tree of life that led to us
from Luca to us
and
the shadow biosphere is telling us that
there is
or there are other pathways
that came up at the time where life
originated but they are so different
that we cannot recognize them as being
living
and we cannot pick them up in our test
because our tests are being built to
recognize Life as we know it and for me
again I don't know if this Theory
will be verified or it would be
discredited but what I like about it is
that it forces me to think on how do I
look for life I don't know
so let's start here on our planet not
even with Little Green Men uh it starts
with very simple life that be can be so
different
that it might be just right in front of
our nose and we don't see it so that
probably starts with the the scientific
humility of always
realizing that
we might be too biased in understanding
of what is the phenomena we're trying to
study yeah I don't like the term bias
because it involves some moral
connotation that yeah
in terms of scientific pathway
intellectual framework definitely what
do you think about the
UFO sightings so the widespread
experiences that people have and seeing
different phenomena that they sort of
that are mysterious that people project
ideas about whether it's aliens or not
but they can't explain it and there's
pictures and data and then the
government is involved in releasing
footage and all that kind of stuff and
that seems to Captivate the public it
always imagine it always do I mean you
know there are a number of things that
uh Captivate people especially children
actually dinosaurs and aliens still a
child yeah we are also child at heart
and
um so about UFOs I am a Scientist and
I'm a citizen so I'm going to tell you a
couple of things first I don't mind
talking about that at all because I
think as a scientist this is extremely
interesting because the thing I don't
know
I want to learn about it this is more
knowledge so we all know the statistics
about UFOs
95 percent of them are just natural
phenomenon or things that are being
misinterpreted we know that then you
have the two percent that might be
secret programs by whatever government
it's out there
another person say is about natural
phenomenon that we don't know about here
that we cannot explain and then there is
this tiny percentage that don't fall
into all these categories of thing and I
think that the re the report about the
uaps falls into the same kind of scheme
except that now they have at least some
patterns of speed of other things that
were in the report today we don't know
if these sightings are
part of military program or actual UFOs
I always run into that question because
of course as the Director of the car
second Center at the study Institute I
received a number of emails about the
subject people actually
confused about what the study Institute
is we are not studying UFOs we are
studying we are actually looking for
messages the way I put it you know
usually is that we are studying
extraterrestrial in their natural
habitat yes and and the UFO people are
trying to understand whether they
invaded our aerial space yes so this is
very two very different things and
unfortunately over the years I actually
respect very much people who are trying
to go to the bottom of what UFO are
following some very
scientific ways of doing this they are
very very credible agencies doing this
unfortunately there is a folklore around
UFOs and this has been a huge disservice
to the scientific community and this is
why you have been having that much
pushback for a long time by the
scientific Community because no
Congressman in the world wants to tell
their taxpayer that they are supporting
something that looking for flying
saucers and you know when you see what's
happening it's terrifying and I am
actually
concerned you know about that
relationship that people do between
folklore and real search for
extraterrestrial intelligence
in fact it's been so bad that
until today
there is no government agency that is
actually funding the city search it is a
private funded endeavor
what NASA funds right now which is a
progress is a search for techno
signature which means that when you are
looking at the atmosphere of a planet
you look for some disequilibrium that
could tell you that something is there
but it's not going to found a an
Institute or whatnot that is looking for
messages or or other things like that
does that just have to do with the taboo
associated with the folklores yes and I
think there was a pushback from the
political
Arena
decades ago about that at the time where
all the Flying Saucer were coming out uh
and then the city Institute got it
started so
um but now there is more of a
willingness to look at the UAP uh UFO uh
phenomenon from a scientific standpoint
so much so that the government is
actually seeking some help from a
scientific institution and there are
programs to start looking into those
phenomenon and as a scientist I am
interested what I'm not interested in
again Carl Sagan comes back here I don't
want to believe I want to know and so to
know you have to have a real experiment
you have to have observation and you
have uh things that are done the right
way I don't want to have somebody that
start with what if as a question and
then turns this what if in into the only
argument and the only conclusion there
is you understand but still I think it's
valuable to appreciate the mystery and
not deny the mystery so no the mystery
is there but what I don't want is people
taking advantage of the public and
making money out of folklore well let me
flip that I understand but so there's a
folklore and like the stuff I do Ai and
Robotics for example there's a clear
fear Terminator and movies and all those
kind of stuff you could say that I'm
very concerned about this miscalibrated
uh understanding of the public of what
robots role are in society or you could
see it as a let's use a metaphor of a
wave you can say this giant wave
they'll call folklore is a really bad
idea we need to uh avoid it we need to
hide we need to build dams or you can be
a surfer and ride the wave as a
scientist
to me the fact that people are wondering
about the mystery of UFOs it means
they're wondering no they are but the
thing I I will stop surfing that wave
when it comes back to bite an entire
scientific discipline that's the science
sure for now the past 60 years
we were not able to raise money from the
government no grants it's a discipline
that has no postdoc of very little
postdoc just because there is a fear of
that folklore on the political Arena
people don't want to be associated with
that because they confuse the two so I
stopped
there and as the Director of the Carl
Sagan Center I am just very happy to see
now that there is a course correction
in the government seeking scientific
investigators for this kind of issues
and hopefully that will write the ship
there I love it I love to see it but I
want and I love her a little
disagreements I'm I'm doing so obviously
respectfully and with love and it's it
makes it for a fun conversation but I
think you know just like with surfing a
wave there there's some level of if the
more you resist it the worse it is so I
we didn't resist it yes it didn't come
from us and we paid the price
I just think that
the role of a scientists in part in the
21st century when we talked about social
media it's to direct this sense of
wonder that people have
into a direction of the rigors of
science I think we do that pretty well I
would disagree I don't think Society
does much better but there's other
places in science where research for
life is filled it fairly easy place to
you know draw The Wonder of people yes
because it's a profound question that
pretty much everybody has but I think I
just want to highlight the fact that I
think a lot of scientists my colleagues
friends
think that all you need to do is science
all you need to do is this the
scientific process the peer review
process the the data and so on but I
think communication is actually a
fundamental part of the process
um because it has to do with funding but
also has to do like we're we're a bunch
of humans trying to ask big questions
trying to figure this whole puzzle out
and nobody agree we do have more Public
Presentation at The Institute than
peer-reviewed articles and believe me we
have a lot of peer-reviewed Articles so
our scientists are out there and they
are sharing The Wonder of discoveries
and it's so easy these days I mean there
is not one day tell me about writing a
book right now about the search for life
in the universe I mean it's almost every
single day I had to correct something in
the chapters I was writing so study in
terms of both signatures and signals is
a pretty active field so it's getting
better right now uh it's getting better
but remember that the city Institute is
not only about the search foreign is
your intelligence this is the root of
the historical route of the Institute
but it's about 10 percent of what we do
in fact we are searching for life in the
universe from the origins of life to
extraterrestrial intelligence so 90 of
everything else is exoplanet uh for
instance we have a good chunk of the
capital team that is actually with the
study Institute and they are working
with tests right now some already have
some time on the gems web we have
astrobiologists we have astronomers and
those are looking for data for signals
for planets out there go outside of
ourselves and yeah go to analog places
to try and understand the type of life
that survive in planetary type
environments I mean people are always
surprised when I tell them you know
whatever flies in the source system a
swan or will be flying
we're involved so this is not something
that pops in everybody's mind when they
are thinking about the the study
Institute because we started off as the
search for extraterrestrial intelligence
but the Institute has really bloomed
into the search for Life along the Drake
equation all the terms of the Drake
equation just to clarify Because by the
way you're saying a bunch of terms
sometimes it's good to return to the
basics when you're saying whatever's
flown
seti is a part of the things that are
flown so we because we're using we
elusive sometimes it's that we humans
and sometimes we study yeah so the
studies is really broadly involved a lot
of the fingertips reaching out there
towards the stuff think about Mars
involved in landing site selection in
instruments that are actually on board
some of the mission in science teams for
instance uh Cassini uh New Horizon also
missions that will be coming it's the
search for life we do this all across
the Drake equation so uh studies part of
it and it's a root and it's
expanding a little bit right now we hope
it will continue to expand so this is
this is a good time uh for the Institute
and it also uh in my mind was the very
first astrobiology Institute because we
have this multi-discient disciplinary
approach where I can bring many of the
scientists from different domains and
disciplines to think about the question
and as you know discoveries happen at
the Nexus of disciplines and it's really
a privilege when when you are in an
Institute like that